[Music]
brett joins us up next in atlanta
georgia brett welcome to the show
hey george thanks for taking my call
today absolutely what's going on
yeah so i've heard the
study of the 10 000 millionaires and how
they're all able to pay off their loans
quickly and that's how they i guess
credit themselves to becoming a
millionaire uh my question is
basically i can't wrap my head around
how it mathematically makes sense to pay
off super low interest rate loans versus
paying
all of that overage money to buy stock
that's currently on sale today i know
that there's risk involved
but i'm 27 years old my wife and i we
both work and i rarely look at my stock
account whether the market is up or down
i just
don't care i guess i'm risk adverse
so i can definitely go into some of the
scenario about where we are at in life
how much we're making how much we have
saved up how much those loans are
uh right now two car loans at thirty
seven thousand at a one point nine eight
percent fixed interest rate rental
property loan at 140 000 at a 3.25
fixed interest rate and then personal
home mortgage loan of 185 000 at 2.75
fixed interest rate okay what's your
household income
anywhere between two hundred and fifty
to three hundred thousand dollars a year
i love it well you've got a nice big
shovel that helps with everything
definitely so
your question was why would i pay off
the loans when i could just invest all
that money
yeah the overage i mean i'm 27 so i'm
guessing 30 plus years of compound
interest work and it's magic
so at 27 let's just say you didn't have
a payment in the world how many what do
your payments all add up to on your
mortgage your rental property the car
payments
uh monthly payment of one car is 460
another monthly payment is 5.65
rental property
payment is 9.50 and then home mortgage
is 1075. okay so about three thousand
let's call that three grand what i want
you to do is go to a compound interest
calculator and put three grand in there
every month for the next 40 years
tell me what that adds up to
and then tell me do you want to keep
those loans around or is that money
better off invested
okay i think i win
i'm playing the tortoise game you're
playing the hair game and that's fine
you know i'm not mad you're still gonna
be a millionaire we'll get there
different ways but the way to do it
without risk and with a little more
financial peace which let me tell you as
you get older and you start having a
family all those loans hanging around
aren't gonna add any security to your
life
now you can do it brett's way and
honestly you'll be fine you're a sharp
dude at 27 you know a thing or two but
as for me and my house we just don't do
payments that's a value that we've
adopted early on and it's it's an
identity thing for me it's not about
math it's about the kind of person i am
is the kind of guy who doesn't need to
answer to anybody and when i don't have
a payment in the world which i don't
because i paid off my house in december
man i'm a light as a feather come at me
bro
if i lost my job today which god willing
if the show goes well dave doesn't do
i'm okay i have an emergency fund i
don't owe anyone anything and so that's
the kind of mindset that i want you to
have you don't have to have it you don't
have to share all my values but you
called into the show and asked me for my
opinion and you got it and it's worth
what you paid for my friend